[Music]
you
why state earthbound when prosperity
awaits you in the Stars got to help seal
the only colony on the edge of the
frontier owned and operated by
corporations a trip of ten short years
will feel like mere minutes thanks to
the comfort and safety of your very own
hibernation chamber you'll wake up in a
perfect society designed to maximize
your productivity with guaranteed full
employment with only a minor term of
service you will become the master of
your own destiny
when you go out of this world to the
halcyon call
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of colonists left
a drifter here forever
just to keep from damaging the board's
bottom line disgraceful
[Music]
muscular atrophy is practically a hobby
in this colony
[Music]
it's as if you are psychologically
incapable of feeling anxiety
you are going to paint the system red my
friend
our fellow tinkerer
[Music]
maybe you can do something about this
lump in my neck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looks to be your lucky day my dress
[Music]
not likely
bootlickers
initiate skip jump
[Music]
structural integrity down 25% power
levels down
you are wondering what's going on there
I'm afraid it's called I guess we'll see
supplies saving you I know it's a lot to
ask but I must have your help securing
more if we're to save the rest of your
fellow colonists I see done myself of
course but now my ship is inoperative
but I've managed to hire a smuggler to
help you out it'll be oh I see we're in
position
good luck
you
you
can you hear me is this thing working ah
there you are now where were we oh yes
your smuggler it's name is Hawthorne and
he should be waiting for you at the
landing site seems to be your chauffeur
so to speak and not to worry I'm told he
is a specialist dashing gunslinger
one-of-a-kind ship of that sort of thing
you'll like him I'm sure I've also
outfitted you with a simple wireless
monitor so I can track your progress
I'll check in with you as soon as you
land good luck I'm all colonists are
counting on you
[Music]
ah you've landed good Hawthorne it
should be close by
what in-laws name is that him
that idiot I told him to plant a beacon
and move away not stand there holding it
oh well no sense in letting his ship go
to waste
[Music]
you